[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing muggles
wizards and magic however we're going to
go a little of course from the usual
style of video
as we will not only be discussing the
existence of magic in the harry potter
universe
but including the lord of the rings
universe as well
in addition to identifying the key
differences for what constitutes magic
in both worlds
i'm going to try to attempt to identify
which world of magic
is more powerful for years decades we've
known about both of these universes
and we've accepted them both for what
they are but what i want to do today is
put them head to head and answer the
question once and for all
who's more powerful harry potter wizards
or lord of the rings wizards
the first thing that i want to say is
that both harry potter and lord of the
rings
are behemoths in media they've each
cultivated some of the biggest
followings
and have established their own unique
devoted fan bases around both books
and films while they are certainly
rivals in the space
they definitely share a mutual audience
and though they are both in the realm of
fantasy
they're more than different enough to
harmoniously co-exist
one thing is for certain though and
that's the fact that lord of the rings
has been around for
longer much longer in fact tolkien
published the first installment of lord
of the rings the fellowship of the ring
in 1954. the next two books were
published in the 15 months that followed
the fellowship of the ring movie however
took a blasphemous
47 years to come out as it wasn't
released until 2001.
coincidentally 2001 was also the year
that the first harry potter film came
out
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
which had only been published in book
form
four years earlier 2001 was a great year
for cinema
two of the most popular novels had
suddenly come to the big screen
and all at once i went to go see both
films and theaters when they came out
though i was only nine years old and
i'll outwardly state that i have a
preference for harry potter
hence the harry potter youtube channel i
was enthralled by the different worlds
of magic placed before me
each approaching the concept of a
fantasy world in their own unique way
the first harry potter was quite
innocent and childlike as the characters
were still young
and the story had yet to develop however
they certainly nailed the sense of
magic that they were going for as the
hogwarts boat scene brings forth a level
of nostalgia
unparalleled to this day the darker tone
that the film developed as they
progressed
fit the story perfectly and eased us
into the darker side of magic
similarly the first lord of the rings
graced our screens with what can only be
described
as a grandiose cinematic experience
giving us a different
flavor of magical world but aside from
the different music
scenery and overall aesthetic how does
magic differ from franchise to franchise
to identify these differences we need to
look the origins of magic in each
franchise
in the harry potter universe witch's
wizards are essentially
advanced or mutated human beings they
have advanced physiologies
heightened perception and if trained
enough have ability to control the
world's elements to some extent
basically witches and wizards are just
enhanced humans
which means that their existence
pre-magic is the same as the original
ancestors of humans who were thought to
have first existed about 6 million years
ago
over millions of years humans developed
and evolved and so it shouldn't be
surprising to anyone
that eventually humans started showing
supernatural capabilities
the ability to perform magic though the
origins of wizard kind and harry potter
are
undefined we do have some information
about the first
known magical being the first known
wizard across all continents was a
wizard by the name of jijamanek
who hailed from egypt as far back as
2600 bc
there was little to no information
available on jujamineck other than where
he was from
and the period in which he lived but i
do wonder if wizard kind went back
further than that
or if he was truly the first the origins
of magic are still unclear to this day
no one knows whether the inception of
wizard kind was born from humans
randomly discovering their magical
abilities or if it was created in some
form
by way of pact ritual or potion i'm
personally of the impression that the
discovery of magic was a genetic
mutation
or perhaps the next logical step in
human evolution
either way witches and wizards are
humans this is where things differ from
lord of the rings in a
big way but before we get into that
let's just wrap up
magic in harry potter by seeing how jk
rowling envisions the concept of magic
in the harry potter universe magic is a
supernatural force that changes aspects
of the world at fundamental levels
the ability for humans to use magic is a
hereditary trait
passed down from a person's ancestors
which allows witches and wizards to
practice it
rather than being a mystical or
unnatural pursuit that defied the laws
of nature
however magic simply allowed those who
could wield it
to exploit them in very specific and
creative ways that muggle sciences were
unable to replicate
different species in harry potter like
goblins and elves
seem to use this same magic and there
are no apparent differences in the type
of magic that they perform
all magical forms of life in harry
potter simply possess the ability to
wield magic and it's not necessarily
that they themselves are magical
only that they are able to take
advantage of the magic around them
witches and wizards in harry potter have
the magic gene but the difference here
is that the wizards in all of the rings
represent the elements themselves
they are the forces of nature
personified like harry potter there are
many types of magical beings in lord of
the rings
elves dwarves ants and even humans the
difference here however is that each of
these magical creatures has their own
brand and level of magic some humans are
able to perform
basic levels of magic like aragorn and
his healing but most of them can't
and those who can most likely learn
their abilities from the elves
elvenkind are among the most powerful of
the magical beings
and seem to be able to do things like
forge magical artifacts manipulate
nature
etc the witches and wizards of the harry
potter universe
besides possessing the magical gene have
some other notable physiological
benefits that make them
advanced humans these traits include
longer lifespans
though not to a significant extent and a
resistance to most common illnesses
lord of the rings is on another level
altogether here because believe it or
not
the bodies of elves live indefinitely in
middle earth
they can be killed or so badly injured
that their spirits forsake their bodies
but if left alone
they will live forever the only
immortals in the harry potter universe
are phoenixes which are destined to
undergo the same
death birth cycle for their entire
existence largely superseding all of the
aforementioned creatures in both
universes
however are the wizards of lord of the
rings the maya
unlike harry potter the wizards of the
lord of the rings series are not humans
at all
in fact they are basically angels
created by the god
eru the one to be divine beings there
were at least 15
likely more created by eru and at one
point five of the maya
living in valinor the land where all
gods live gave up their angel form to
become humanoid
in order to live in ardha middle earth
and help the other creations
humans elves dwarfs etc two
blue wizards went east to live with
humans radagast the brown went to the
woods to help animal life
gandalf the grey traveled all over
helping those who needed it
and sariman the white lived in isingard
to lead the white council
here's the truth and it's a tough pill
to swallow because i'm obviously a huge
harry potter fan
the magic exhibited in lord of the rings
is far more powerful than the magic in
harry potter
the witches and wizards of harry potter
are more comparable to the elves of lord
of the rings than the wizards
and that's not because harry potter
magic isn't powerful but it's because
maya are divine beings maya are the
forces of nature
they are the onlookers of earth its
inhabitants and all of the elements that
exist
take gandalf for example who is often
compared to dumbledore
though dumbledore is unequivocally wise
gandalf is basically omniscient
he has knowledge of all intelligent life
forms on the planet and is responsible
for communication with all of them
to defeat evil sauron another maya has
the power to create life
trolls ogres orcs and radagast can
control all animals
these wizards possess power unparalleled
by a harry potter equivalent
and while dumbledore voldemort
grindelwald are about as close as you're
going to get
they are still nothing to the maya the
maya and body magic
they don't just channel it and they
possess the ability to control
influence people with their words alone
the best example of powerful magic
displayed in harry potter
is probably the duel between voldemort
and dumbledore in the ministry atrium
and to put things into perspective elves
in lord of the rings
who also possess the ability to control
the elements could have put on a
comparable battle
at the end of the day however each
franchise just approaches the concept of
magic in their own unique way
magic in all of the rings seems to have
more dimensions to it
and is viewed in a sort of spiritual
context
magic in harry potter has more of a
utilitarian feel
and is more about using magic to help
overcome the problems or obstacles in
front of you whichever way you look at
it
both universes did a great job at
establishing their own unique approach
to a world of magic
what do you guys think did you ever
wonder which world of magic was more
powerful
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
remember time will not slow down when
something unpleasant lies ahead